[Music]
this is outnumbered hello everybody i'm
harris faulkner along with my co-host
emily compagno kaylee mcinerney also
joining us today kennedy and charlie
hurt just a quick pause here
charlie you ready to put the hurting on
the politics yes indeed it is so nice to
see everybody's face i know right yes
yes thanks for being here all right
let's roll we'll get into the big
headline for now after more than a year
of masking up at the airport other
public transportation we have finally
reached this moment
it's over
immediately
congratulations
[Music]
david and judge overturn the mass
mandate
my company yeah
my company announces at this moment if
you choose to you may remove your mask
i don't know that's the reaction i get
when the mountain dew is free anyway
passengers rejoicing after a pilot
announced mid-flight that the cdc's
federal mass mandate
no longer applies a federal judge in
florida ruled yesterday the biden
administration did not have the
authority to continue enforcing that
mandate the white house called the
decision disappointing our own peter
ducey reminded press secretary jinsaki
that the media have been allowed to go
masculist for weeks in her presence
what about this mass ruling out of a
federal court in florida that it's a
disappointing decision and you say you
continue to recommend that people wear
masks
why is it that we can sit here in the
white house briefing room with no masks
but people
can't sit in an airplane cabin with no
masks well peter i'm not a doctor these
determinations remember the masking
guidance is there are is green yellow
and red we are currently in a green zone
in washington dc so they're not
recommending it
kaylee
yeah it reminds me of uh define a woman
i'm not a biologist that seems to be a
favorite of libs these days um she also
was asked is the mass mandate still in
effect to which she replied i don't know
okay well you're the press secretary you
know how government works that's a
snarky answer the answer is we respect
the opinions of the federal judiciary
including that of a federal judge in
florida but that's not what you said
biden administration calling this
disappointing harris i was mid-flight
last night
middle of my flight the flight attendant
stands there and says breaking news if
you want to take off your mask take off
your mask how about that there were
cheers there was an eruption there was
joy so if the biden administration wants
to express disappointment as america
collectively cheers they can try to do
that but i hope jin saki at the podium
today fights very hard against this
ruling i hope president biden does i
hope they show the true autocrats they
are because that's exactly what they are
and also shame on those talking about
this federal judge i've met her
i've met her at the federalist society
and spoken to her she's a smart woman
four federal judicial clerkships worked
at jones day yeah go ahead go after her
go after america we're all celebrating
you you probably saw your friend and
cohort jose arus emino on with me just a
little bit ago and he said what you said
as democrats they need to respect what
this judge has gone because if it
becomes a political pawn they won't win
on this jose's a smart guy kennedy
people are ready to move on people in
both parties um you know politically
this has been a losing issue for the
democrats but practically this is the
decision we should have been living
under for the last year and a half and
people know that and you touched on this
in your last hour if you are
immunocompromised if if it is unsafe for
you to come in contact with a variety of
microbes you should be masking and that
is your choice and people who need to
protect themselves they know enough at
this point in the virus that that's what
they have to do
but arbitrary mandates this judge called
it capricious
they are
an overreach of federal power and a
violation of what was intended in the
first place which was an abuse of the
word sanitation which is supposed to
refer to sanitizing things and not
people so this is how you get into a
federal pickle i'm glad that this judge
put the although there are some
hand-washing rules i'd like to put into
play but that's that was before the
pandemic watching grown folk walk out of
a public restroom doing the pat pat
yikes emily uh the best pickle i ever
got into was at the beta breakers in san
francisco wearing a tutu me against a
security oh we have time i was caught go
on please we got it so here's the thing
arbitrary and capricious that's a legal
standard and to your point that
absolutely this decision should have
been handed down quite a long time ago
now this judge ruled that this this
authority was outside the scope in fact
of the authority of the cdc it violated
the administrative procedures act and in
addition to being arbitrary and
capricious which basically means that
it's it's not within your scope of
authority and it's not based on some
type of superseding data that moves that
out of the way
it also violated the rule making and
comment period required before federal
rules now there's a procedure set up in
this country that we have to respect and
that's why there's so much power vested
in the people to vote right because we
respect the process and we respect thus
our elected officials to carry that out
so i find it fascinating when jen saki
says she's disappointed by this because
as a citizen as an american i'm
disappointed by our administration
acting outside the scope of their
authority i am disappointed every day by
this white house abusing their authority
abusing their bloated power like every
other federal agency under this
so-called pandemic that has dragged on
longer than a zombie you know i'm glad
you broke it down along those legal
terms because kaylee when you were
describing the capriciousness
of you can take your mask off now right
i mean look at how the science flipped
on a flight yep
right i mean or were they never really
paying as much attention to the science
yeah i mean were they real was that
really the deciding factor ever for many
of those leaders would be my question
all right so we're just now learning
that if you are on air force one and
you're headed to new hampshire with the
president today because he's going to do
the uh bipartisan infrastructure to
continue promoting the things that the
administration says it's done well uh if
you're on that flight
you have to wear a mask there's a mask
mandate on that flight yeah so
apparently the uh the new freedom
doesn't extend to air force one um no i
mean all and you know they can try to
dismiss this and belittle this and jenn
saki can talk about disappointed the
white house is in all of this um but if
what however disappointed they are in
this ruling they're disappointed in the
constitution because all of these rules
are are not just capricious rules the
rules are designed to protect our
liberties and it's supposed to be
difficult to take people's liberties
away that's the whole point of the
process that's why we're all on this
crazy island together uh under the same
constitution is because we want it to be
difficult and so i think it's a it's a
great triumph for freedom and by the way
if you are compromised if you need to
wear a mask or you want to wear a mask
you can still wear a mask it's choice
and it will provide precisely the
protection that a mask provides yeah and
you know kennedy what we were discussing
last hour on the faulkner focus there
are people who were wearing masks before
i mean you would see the elderly and
some who were tender
who can't get a flu vaccine for instance
or can't get a whole host of things and
wet spittle was maybe something that
they want to protect themselves from
and so their doctors may tell them that
that's that's a good idea for them to to
do that but this is about choice and i
take this as the same category with
everything else the cdc says is a choice
and there's a long list and and i i hope
and pray that what we don't wind up with
is a continuation of the divisions
because the divisions uh between people
that are doing one thing and not doing
the other uh it's tearing us apart and
it's not good and so we i guess we have
to remember to have uh you know grace
and empathy we were talking about it a
minute ago uh for for you know obviously
there are going to be people out there
who need to wear a mask and
some people may choose to wear for
health reason absolutely you should if
you're immuno compromised but some
people will wear it as a political state
oh don't you know that you think that
that will happen oh
yes and what does it tell the world
what is your statement look at the fact
that 80
of those passengers going through reagan
airport in dc are still wearing a mask
this is like joe biden central hub i
don't think 80 are immuno-compromised i
think they're making a political
statement well they're all calling for a
boycotti in those airlines that dared to
respect the federal judge's decision and
say all right masks are not mandatory
delta american spirit united i'm in
favor of god i hope they boycott all of
them well and that i it calls someone
you know for alaska for example that was
the one that i used to watch that video
i told you guys about where it told me
that the air was only 60 seconds old and
it was the safest place to be
essentially on the planet the cleanest
air heaven forbid that we are allowed to
exist in that little capsule without a
mask so is the white house press
briefing room apparently kova doesn't
transmit among celebrities and reporters
exactly this is so much fun